well we're finally here tears of the
Kingdom releases this year and yet
breath of the wild still has more things
to show us so we're gonna keep making
videos about them if you continue to
follow this series and want us to keep
going through to the sequel just hit
that like button here we go
throughout the game most Lookout Towers
have centuries in charge of guarding
enemy and kamets and they're pretty much
always equipped with warning horns
calling for backup when enemies are
spotted in most cases though this job is
totally dedicated to bokoblins and Los
Altos moblins and lionels never got
these but at some point they were
thinking about giving them horns as well
in the book creating a champion there's
a photo showing all the horn designs for
not only vocabulins and lesolfos but
moblins and lionels as well the moblin's
horn seems to be a long spiral type
animal horn while the Lionel's version
appears to be handmade with bits of
scrap metal and a connecting chain
on the same note developers initially
had a hard time choosing a natural
sounding horn and were thinking of using
traditional instruments like the French
horn
but a programmer suggested they use his
horny hat at home and after bringing it
to the studio the team chose to use it
as it created a great sound for the game
new year new glitch breath of the wild
still has discoveries that lets us see
the game in new ways the newest
additions include a glitch called map
storage and arms no not the game arm map
storage stores the compendium or map
screen while the game is still running
live allowing you to control both at the
same time this can lead to playing the
game in a semi-2d old-school style
format from the top down
arms on the other hand is an addition to
map storage which allows link to have
complete invincibility infinite stamina
and true freedom of the map being able
to go and climb anywhere without being
voided out as well as storing weather
effects and carrying them across the map
this can lead to some neat situations
such as freezing snow in the Gerudo
desert
sweltering heat waves in the korok
forest
or even raining thunderstorms on Death
Mountain
most players knock down trees with a
wood Cutter's ax or double ax which
takes down trees and one to two swings
but by using a cutting weapon that does
less damage or even one damage such as
the one hit obliterator with each swing
the cut actually gets slightly deeper
and deeper until the tree is fully cut
trees by the way have 40 HP and it's
just that tree cutting weapons such as a
woodcutter's ax and double ax do bonus
damage you know your good friend the
sand seal helping you cross a desert
sands easily but did you know that
different seals have different speeds
rental seals and seals lend to you
during special events will be the faster
seal while seals caught in the wild will
be a little bit slower
here's a bunch of back-to-back small
details about Rito Village they of
course have little windmills catching
wind scattered about the town but if you
take a closer look these windmills are
just a bunch of tiny kites attached to
each other most players have never
bothered to actually look but have you
seen a Rideau sleeping you can often see
the Rito kids sleeping on the low lower
levels because they are shorter but for
a full-grown readers you'll have to
climb a little bit higher to catch up
napping up in their hammock at night and
they even have a whole special animation
of getting up and jumping down out of
their bed
and on top of that even though it's
impossible to talk to them at this angle
if you use a small step ladder you can
actually get high enough to interact
with them while they're sleeping if you
look around the Rito kids sleeping area
there's a bunch of cute chalk drawings
scattered about each pillar of the room
such as little dragonflies fish apples
and butterflies if you scare the Weedle
kids with a remote bomb and then have
them talk to you you can have them
combine their singing notes to you
[Music]
creating a champion explains how Rito
houses have platforms on the backside
for villagers to take off and land
straight from their house funny thing is
most of these houses have another
platform in them as well this tiny one
on the upper left way too small for a
standard Reno to sit on well at least
you can hang out up there
breath of the wild has hundreds of
special conversation checks that you may
have never run across you can catch the
young readers singing next to the shrine
and if you talk to gently she'll thank
you for getting her outside to sing but
if you collected 120 shrines gently
instead congratulates you and tells me
I'm a good boy I guess I'm a dog now
another small one is how conversation
changes at The Lover's pond with wabin
and purda while it's raining and not
raining while Ben comments on her beauty
in the rain and Perth notes that she
doesn't want to get her flowers wet in
the rain at sasakai Shrine Cass sings a
riddle to hint at Players to shoot at
the sun while in the shika Tower's
Shadow thing is there's actually a
second opportunity to do this shooting
the moon at night works just as well
because the Moon is a reflection of the
Sun's light at sumasama Shrine players
are hinted at using a snowball to cast a
shadow on a special switch to unlock it
but this Shadow mechanic is not tied
specifically to a snowball any item that
cast a shadow Works including crionus
blocks
barrels metal boxes treasure chests and
even big enough weapons can do the trick
[Music]
players may have witnessed some electric
lizolfos have some strange properties
with water if one is found in rain or in
shallow water it'll partially or fully
be wrapped in a conducted electricity
Bowl but try the choo choo jelly version
instead drenching them with choo choo
jellies will cause them to create a much
larger one of these
in many quests link is given small
rewards using the form of materials but
what happens if you're giving these
rewards when you have 999 of said
material well you won't be able to get
the reward which makes sense but what's
interesting is that the developers
thought ahead of this situation and
actually made unique dialogue for each
NPC in every one of those situations
examples such as coyan saying she
recommends you drink up and sell off
your milk to make room or may telling
you to hurry up and Sell Your staminaoka
Bass to make room in your bag
collecting 999 milks without glitches
sounds like a very daunting task one of
the most common glitches players have
run into is making inactive Guardians
clip through the ground using stasis
it's because this half sunken into the
ground position the Guardians were
placed at were a little bit buggy with
these Guardians though if you win bomb
or BLS as quickly to them before they
have a chance to load in and then go
into bullet time just as they appear
they start to go a little bonkers
thank you
here's a fact that I unfortunately
cannot show you without the use of a mod
because we don't have the ability to
control where Talus spawn but trust me
when I say this is how the developers
designed this did you know that Talus
actually have Auto camouflaging skin in
the base game when they first spawn in
they actually read what Bedrock material
they're on and match it to their own
skin this lets us see many teleskins
that could have been possible in normal
gameplay but were never seen such as
this dirt and brick combination this
loose gray gravel and plant combination
a material we've shown in a previous
episode called Cliff cheese and Ash and
black Talus and even a cobblestone Talus
while again yes the talus placement is a
mod these skins you see are not modded
this is breath of the Wild's engine
naturally at work and we never got to
see his true potential in the base game
what was your favorite thing you learned
this time let us know in the comments
below of course we will keep going with
this series into tears of the Kingdom
where we'll continue to gather a bunch
of facts for you but for everything else
keep it here on Gamespot
foreign
[Music]